let me bring you some breaking news a
london court has ruled that wikileaks
founder julian assange can be extradited
to the united states the 50 year old
could now face trial in the u.s for
publishing classified military documents
about the wars in afghanistan and iraq
on nadine baba is joining me now from
live outside the court in london
what's been happening inside the court
well rob the decision has just come and
mr assange's supporters here are being
briefed i've heard a cry of a disgrace
because lawyers for the united states
have won their appeal
against the decision early this year
that he shouldn't be extradited to the
united states now the judges the two
judges here have considered arguments by
lawyers for the us and julian assange
made in october the u.s was saying that
basically
the decision
not to extradite him was based uh solely
on his mental health and the
risks the potential risks of suicide if
he were held in isolation in a super mac
so-called super max jail in the us well
they said he wouldn't have to be held in
such conditions and they'd had
diplomatic assurances that he could
serve any jailed sentence in australia
they also suggested that there are other
circumstances that should have been
taken into account such as the fact that
he now has two children by his partner
stella morris
his uh lawyers said that um those
assurances didn't really mean anything
and they also brought up the matter of
reports uh not denied by the cia that
there had been a plot to assassinate
julian assange when he was in the
ecuadorian embassy well now we have the
decision uh it's a big win for the us
which argues that he uh broke the law by
conspiring to uh obtain and publish
confidential uh wires thousands of them
about the war in afghanistan and iraq he
has been supported all along by rights
groups such as reporters without borders
which say that he has he acted as a
journalist and that this raises very
serious questions about the freedom of
speech
what happens next nadine
all right now julian assange will be
heading back to belmarsh prison here in
london where he's been since 29
now he was actually following uh the
events here as he was in october via a
video link the parties here concerned
were not uh present
it's possible that julian assange can
now appeal this decision at the supreme
court here in london the whole process
could potentially take years of course
this is not a good outcome for him
particularly given what we know about
his health and the warnings that have
come from stella morris and his
supporters about his uh mental condition
they are extremely worried as well about
the precedent this that this could set
if he were eventually to be sent to the
united states but right now that could
be some way off nadine thank you very
much indeed just to remind you of that
breaking news from london the london
court has ruled that wikileaks founder
julian assange can be extradited to the
united states
that followed a ruling that uk judges
had upheld a u.s government appeal
against the bloc on julian assange's
extradition the 50 year old man could
now face trial in the u.s for publishing
classified military documents about the
wars in afghanistan and iraq will bring
you live pictures from outside the court
where that hearing has been held you can
see supporters of julian assange outside
there are very vocal in their opposition
to the result of this hearing